The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: I have
a tiring day today.
Just 10 minutes ago, I finished
chairing the first part
of a meeting of the
COA advisory committee.
And I gave a talk to them.
And right after the
lecture, I have to go back.
So while they have a lunch
break, I have to teach.
But that's OK.
That's life on the faculty.
Yes.
We're talking about applications
of the spontaneous light force.
We have used optical
block recreations and such
to learn about the spontaneous
force, the stimulated force,
in general.
And this is our expression for
the spontaneous light force.
It's pretty much, the
momentum of photons
is transferred to the atom
times to scattering rate.
And what we started last class,
and we want to finish today,
is we want to discuss
applications of this force
to three situations which are
of experimental importance.
One can actually say that
slow beams, more or less,
in the magneto-optical trap
are the key techniques which
triggered a revolution
in atomic physics.
This is really the
enabling technology
into ultracold atom science.
So I discussed with you, in
the last class, molasses.
And we discussed
what happens when
we have two
counterpropagating beams.
Maybe the key figure to
remember is this one.
When we have to
counterpropagating beams,
by just adding up the
spontaneous light force
of the two beams, we get the red
curve, force versus velocity.
And the expert eye immediately
sees there is a linear slope.
And that's a viscous force.
This is the viscosity of
light interacting with atoms.
Of course, you'd better
pick the detuning correctly.
If you use the wrong
detuning, everything
is flipped upside down.
And instead of a damping force,
you have an anti-damping force.
We then discussed
the cooling limit.
Any cooling limit is the balance
between heating and cooling.
And by just setting the heating
rate equal to the cooling rate,
this describes a steady state.
We found the famous
Doppler limit.
OK.
So that's where I
want to continue.
But do you have any
questions about molasses,
the Doppler limit, and what we
discussed in the last class?
Well, I know we had discussions
about to take two beams which
form a standing wave, and
take it apart, and calculate
the force for each beam.
Well, sorry, this is
what molasses is about.
Molasses is about two beams.
And if you want to treat
two interfering laser
beams in the full
generality, there
are a lot of other effects.
Some of them, we
will be uncovering
in the next few lectures.
But I'm happy now, when
I discuss beam slowing,
to give you when there
is only one single laser
beam decelerating atoms.
That is the only
situation I know
about where you have an
exact analytic solution.
So I want to present
it to you know.
Actually, for a number of years,
I presented the exact solution
with one laser beam before
I presented molasses,
where I have to
make approximations.
But I always felt that beam
slowing is more complicated,
because you have to go
to a decelerating frame
and have to add
fictitious forces.
So some of the
intuition is lost.
So that's why I first
presented you with molasses,
with two beams, for which I
need to make approximations.
Because the interference
pattern between two laser beams
has richness and complexity.
But now I discuss
beam slowing with you.
So this curve here
could be the result
of the very early beginnings
of laser cooling in
the late '70s, early '80s.
And this is when people had an
atomic beam with a Boltzmann
distribution, and they had one
laser been counterpropagating.
But the laser beam
had a fixed frequency.
And what is this
laser beam doing?
Well, it resonantly
interacts with the atoms
which just have the
correct Doppler shift
to be in resonance.
Those atoms are pushed--
scattered photons-- are pushed
to lower frequencies--
to lower velocities.
But they are pushed
out of resonance.
And eventually, the slowing
becomes slower and slower.
And eventually, things come,
almost, to a standstill.
So a laser beam which
has a fixed frequency
would modify the
velocity distribution
of an atomic beam in that way.
People called it,
already, cooling.
And I think some
pioneers in Russia
who did those experiments were
disappointed that they were not
honored with a Nobel
Prize in laser cooling.
This was the first cooling.
Because this distribution
here is considerably narrower
than here.
And temperature is nothing
else than a measure
of the reach of the
velocity distribution.
But one can say that
those experiments did not
trigger a revolution
in atomic physics.
The revolution came when
people eventually figured out
how they can narrow down this
peak from maybe a hundred
or tens of kelvins down
to a million microkelvin.
So it's clear what is needed.
If you want to do
more slowing, you
have to make sure
that you are talking
to the other velocities,
and that you eventually
sweep many velocities into one
peak-- clear out the velocity
distribution, collect
all the atoms,
and put them at a
monochromatic velocity.
So for that, you can say, well,
if you use a comb of frequency,
or a broad spectrum
of frequencies,
you could clean
out a larger area.
And, indeed, there
are techniques
like this-- white light slowing
or diffuse light slowing.
But since those
techniques are not
anymore of practical importance,
I don't want to discuss them.
Let me talk about the
simplest technique-- at least,
conceptionally-- which
is chirped slowing.
And this works like follows.
You start with a laser
beam which is initially
in resonance with
the velocity group.
And as the atoms slow down,
you change the detuning
of the laser that the
laser stays in resonance
with the atoms.
So it is a pulsed
technique where
you have a continuous
atomic beam.
You start with a laser and
say, now I start slowing.
And the laser is
following a group of atoms
as they are decelerated.
So you can say it is like the
atoms are riding the surf.
The laser is always
following the atoms
as they change their velocity.
And what is, of course,
necessary for that to happen
is that the chirp and the
deceleration of the atoms
are synchronized.
You will see that
in a moment, when
I put this idea into equations.
There is another technique
which is used in many labs--
actually, in all my labs
and Martin Zwierlein's lab.
It's called Zeeman slowing.
And this is discussed
in your homework.
It is a CW version
of chirped slowing.
And a lot of you
know what I mean.
The physics which goes on
there is almost identical.
But for conceptional
reasons, it's
easier not to use
magnetic fields and such.
Let's just keep it simple.
Let's have one laser beam
talking to a two-level atom.
And the only other ingredient
is the Doppler shift.
Any questions about--
so I've surveyed,
for you, beam slowing.
And now I want to give
you the exact description
for one typical example
of a slowing technique.
And a lot of the results
we find in chirped slowing
apply to other
slowing techniques.
OK.
I know I've taught
it several times.
And there is the
conceptional point
that you can only describe
chirped slowing well
when you go to the decelerating
frame of the atoms.
You want to describe it in
the frame of the atoms which
are continuously
being decelerated.
So the way I can introduce
it is the following.
I take the maximum-- I take
the spontaneous light force.
This is exactly
the expression we
have discussed several times.
And now I'm saying
we decide that we
want to decelerate atoms
with a deceleration, a, which
is negative, because
we slow them down.
Of course, if you pick a too
large that it would require
more than the maximum
spontaneous light force,
you will not find a solution.
But let's simply assume we
want to decelerate atoms
with a deceleration a.
Well, what happens is
this deceleration, a,
requires a certain force.
If the intensity of the laser
would provide more force
on resonance then it's
not going to work.
Because we want to decelerate
the atoms at this deceleration.
So therefore, the atoms,
if they are decelerated,
have to be at a detuning,
delta prime, in such a way
that the spontaneous
light force is exactly
providing the
acceleration we decided
we want to have for our atoms.
In other words, this detuning--
in the frame of the atom,
the atoms are on resonance
when the light force is exactly
providing the force to give
you the acceleration a.
But if you have more laser
power than absolutely necessary,
in the frame of the
atoms, the atoms
have to be detuned in
such a way that the force,
with the detuning,
is exactly providing
the acceleration we want.
So that's the easiest
way to explain it.
We have to set the stage.
We have to introduce
this nominal detuning.
OK.
So you can say that this
detuning is just a definition.
And now we want to describe
the slowing process.
So we have said we want
to start with atoms
at an initial velocity-- which
we'll actually cancel out
in a moment.
But let's do it in
a systematic way--
and afterwards, we want the
velocity to decrease, linearly,
in time.
I simply defined this
parameter, delta prime,
to be a solution
of this equation.
So this is a well
defined quantity.
And the laser detuning--
which, I've broken my laser
to change its detuning
as a function of time--
is now this nominal detuning
minus the Doppler shift
due to the velocity
of the atoms.
I'm really solving the
problem backwards for you.
I first decide which should
be the velocity trajectory
of the atoms-- how should
the atoms slow down.
And then, I define what
is the detuning which
will result in that.
That's the easier
way to understand it.
Of course, if you
pick this detuning,
the atoms will exactly do that.
OK.
But now what we're
doing is the following.
This is sort of the
acceleration and the velocity
we want the atom to have.
But there may be some
atoms in the beam which
do not have this velocity.
They deviate from this
velocity with v prime.
So the goal of
cooling would now be
to reduce v prime to 0 to
make all the atoms follow
the trajectory we have
designed for them.
OK.
Many words, many definitions.
Now we can simply
substitute what
we have defined
into the equation.
And we get a wonderful result.
So we take equation
one, which was
the equation for
the light force.
And we put all
those definitions,
which I went to great lengths
to explain to you, into it.
And we get this result.
It's just that the detuning has
been expressed by delta prime,
and the velocity by this
difference velocity v prime.
It's pure mathematical
substitution.
But now comes the
important point
that we want to describe
everything, now,
in the decelerating frame.
The atoms are meant to
decelerate with a deceleration
a.
And you know, from
classical mechanics,
if you describe something
in a decelerating frame,
you have to add a
fictitious force.
This fictitious force, since
the acceleration is constant,
is a constant force.
But I'm expressing it, now,
by the other parameters.
We've chosen our acceleration.
We've chosen the
detuning, delta prime,
that-- everything is
sort of connected.
And this is just a way to
use the correct-- the most
easiest units, or the
correct parametrization,
for this constant force.
So I have done-- and the
important thing for you
is, this equation is exact.
It's exact for an arbitrary
velocity v prime of the atoms.
So let me just summarize.
I've taken the
spontaneous light force.
I've given you a
bunch of definitions,
what delta prime is.
That's how you
program your laser.
But then, in the
decelerating frame,
we need a fictitious force.
And this is nothing else than
a mathematically exact rewrite
of the spontaneous light force
in the decelerating frame.
But now what happens is--
we had a decelerating--
we had a light force where,
because we assume the laser is
counterpropagating,
there's a minus sign.
The fictitious force
has a plus sign.
And that means that we
can-- and if v prime is 0,
the force is 0.
So we can now make a Taylor
expansion for small v prime.
So we have, again, a viscous
force, a friction force.
And it turns out that
this friction coefficient
for beam deceleration is
exactly 1/2 what we got before,
for molasses.
But it's clear we
have one laser beam.
Whereas in molasses,
we had two laser beams.
If you ask, what is
the heating, well,
if you have one laser beam
and not two laser beams,
the heating described by the
momentum diffusion coefficient
is also just 1/2.
One beam heats exactly half
of what we got for two beams.
And therefore, the
temperature, which
characterizes the width of
the velocity distribution
in the frame of the
decelerating atoms
is exactly the Doppler
temperature we had before.
Because the two
factors of 1/2 cancel.
So now I have given
you-- and I hope
you take some pleasure
in it-- an example where
the laser cooling for
a two-level system
is exactly described.
There's only a single beam.
And the Doppler limit
is the exact solution.
I've not made any
approximation other
than assuming I have a
two-level system for which
the spontaneous light force has
the expression we've derived.
OK.
I know, even with
my explanation,
you have to read through
it once or twice.
Because I made a
few substitutions.
And you really have to
digest them at your own pace.
So let me give you a summary of
what we have done graphically.
One laser beam scatters light.
And it is this Lorentzian.
And it's a negative
Lorentzian because we
have a counterpropagating beam.
We push the atoms into
the negative direction,
they fly in the
positive direction.
But by going-- by
chirping the laser,
by going into the
decelerating frame,
the force doesn't go to 0.
I had to add an offset.
And this offset is
the fictitious force
due to the transformation
of the decelerating frame.
And now you realize
that this force-- and it
is the correct force in the
decelerating frame-- has two 0
crossings.
One is a stable point, and
one is an unstable point.
And the stable point says, if
an atom happens to be too fast,
it gets a correcting force.
And this is like a lock point.
It has a stable lock point.
All the atoms which did not have
the correct velocity we wanted
them to have, they are sort of
sucked into this lock point,
and eventually, will
pile up at a huge peak
at this nominal velocity.
And the width of
this peak is simply
described by the Doppler limit.
Before I take your
questions, let
me show you what happens
in the two frames.
This is v prime.
This is the velocity in
the decelerating frame.
And let's say our
initial velocity is this.
So what happens now is all
the atoms within the atoms
are decelerated towards
v prime equals 0.
The friction force puts
them to v prime equals 0.
But since we are in
a decelerating frame,
in the absence of the laser,
the whole Maxwell-Boltzmann
distribution is
just shifted-- not
because the velocity
of the atoms
changed-- because we are
in a decelerating frame
and we are accelerating
away from the atoms.
And what I just described for
you is the following-- that,
at v prime equals 0, we
have our friction force.
And the atomic
distribution in this frame
is now pushed through.
And everything which goes
through this resonant region
is sort of collected.
And you have a peak which is
piling up at v prime equals 0.
Probably, it's easier--
but mathematically,
I needed the
decelerating frame--
if you use the
following picture.
And just think of this beam
slowing I explained to you.
If you just switched
on a laser here,
you would just burn a hole
into the velocity distribution
and pile up the atoms.
But now you sweep.
And when you sweep, you take
the peak, push it further.
It gets a bigger peak here.
Push it further.
So eventually, what
you're doing is,
by chirping the laser
in the correct way
with the correct laser
power and all that,
you're just pushing
the atoms all out.
And eventually,
they are piled up
in a narrow distribution which
is defined by the time when you
just switch off your laser beam.
So one chirp of the laser,
from an initial detuning
in the lab frame to a final
detuning in the lab frame,
will just sweep out the whole
Maxwell-Boltzmann distribution.
And if you suddenly
switch off the laser,
you have frozen in a velocity
distribution which is exactly
described by the Doppler limit.
So what is easier to
understand-- molasses
with two beams, or beam
slowing with a single beam?
I think molasses is
easier, because everything
happens in the lab frame.
But think about it.
It's a nice example for which no
approximations have to be made.
Questions?
Yes, Nancy.
AUDIENCE: It's not
really obvious to me
how, in this mathematics,
we are choosing
a time-dependent
detuning as opposed
to a time-dependent
deceleration.
PROFESSOR: The way I
presented it logically, we
said we want a certain
acceleration to happen.
And then, we provide our laser
that k/kv is the Doppler shift.
ka is how the Doppler shift
changes as a function of time.
And we chirp our laser
exactly in frequency
with a chirp which is ka.
So in other words, I started
to define a constant a.
And that would require
that the laser is now
chirped in a linear way.
I could have started the
other around and said, hey,
let's assume we chirp the
laser in a linear way.
And then, we do
corresponding substitutions.
And the result
would be the same.
AUDIENCE: No, actually,
like if we did not
want to have a detuning
which was time-dependent,
would we have gotten--
we still have a force.
And that force would
have been just changing.
PROFESSOR: Well then, it's
more complicated, yeah.
Then, you have to integrate
a differential equation.
But what happened
is the following.
What I've done is, by defining
the acceleration and then
the chirp, I have the situation
that, in the reference
frame of the decelerating
atoms, the detuning is constant.
So usually, you go to
a decelerating frame
if something else simplifies.
And what simplifies is that,
in the frame of the atom,
the laser detuning is constant.
So you can also say the frame
in which the atoms decelerate is
exactly the frame in which
the chirp has disappeared.
Because the decelerating
frame compensates
the chirp with a
linearly varying,
time varying Doppler shift.
OK.
But the physics, I
think, is really--
the moment you have a force
which has a 0 crossing,
it's a lock point.
You determine the slope.
And alpha, together with
the momentum diffusion,
gives you the final temperature.
So I hope you enjoy that it's
actually the same physics--
exactly the same
physics-- we discussed,
with some approximation
for molasses.
OK.
We had a discussion last time
about, we have the force,
we find exactly what
happens to the atoms.
But we may have to think
about it in different ways
to figure out where the
kinetic energy goes from.
And I think we mentioned it
already, in the last class,
that what happens is you have
a red-detuned laser, which is,
the photons are absorbed.
But the atom is scattering
light in all directions.
And so if you go
at 90 degrees, you
don't have a linear
Doppler shift.
If you go forward-backward
with the same probability--
a symmetric pattern-- the
Doppler shift averages to 0.
So on average, you emit
photons which are on resonance.
And therefore, every time
you scatter a photon,
you radiate away
the energy which
is equal to the Doppler shift.
That means, initially, when
the Doppler shift is huge,
each photon transports
away a lot of energy.
And the slower the atoms
are, the less a photon
transports away.
But that makes sense.
If you have a huge
velocity and you
subtract h bar k, the
momentum of the photon,
the kinetic energy is
quadratic in velocity.
You know, h bar k, the
momentum transfer of a photon,
takes out more kinetic
energy the faster
the velocity of the atoms is.
So everything makes
sense and is consistent.
OK.
Let's go from the-- we
started with two beams.
We just discussed one
beam, chirped slowing.
And let's go now to what most
of you use in the laboratory--
namely, six beams.
You want to cool in x, y, z.
So you have
one-dimensional molasses
with two beams times 3.
So in the limit that
the intensity is low,
you just add up all the forces.
You say each beam has a
spontaneous light force.
And you add the six
spontaneous light forces up.
At low intensity-- and you
have to take my word for it--
you can ignore all the
interference effect
between the beams.
They can actually lead to
very interesting effects.
I will give you at least a taste
of what will happen-- actually,
a pretty good taste-- what
happens at higher power.
We need the traced atom picture.
And we'll discuss how
the stimulated force
can be used for cooling.
But if you don't have
a two-level system,
you have sigma plus
sigma minus transitions
and the beams interfere, you get
spatially varying polarizations
of your interference
patterns, and then you
have much [INAUDIBLE] physics.
But in the simplest case
of a two-level system,
there is a regime
at low intensity
where you can simply take the
equations we got for molasses
and apply them to XYZ.
I put, on the website, a nice
handout, a review paper by Bill
Phillips, who is discussing 1D
molasses versus 3D molasses,
and if you enjoy
it, you can read
how numerical factors
of 1 or 2 or 3
now appear in the
friction coefficient,
in the heating
coefficient, and how
they affect the
final temperature.
But you got the full [INAUDIBLE]
concepts and the correct idea
for one dimension molasses.
Now, let me give you
an outlook for what
we will be doing next week.
Next week, we want to
understand the following-- what
happens to the
friction coefficient
when you increase the power?
Well, you remember when
we have red-detuned light,
then we had one Lorentzian,
another Lorentzian.
The slope was
negative, and negative
means positive
friction, we cool.
And if you put
more power into it,
the linear slope increases,
and for low power,
the friction coefficient is
proportional to the laser
intensity.
But now look what happens.
If you approach saturation,
then the friction
is not only saturating, it
suddenly changes the sign,
and this is qualitatively new.
And you should a little
bit wonder about it.
Wasn't the reason why we
have cooling that you have
a laser which is red-detuned?
And the photon which is
spontaneously emitted
is on resonance, and this
is the energy difference.
But now I'm telling
you, at high intensity,
it's not the red-detuned
laser which cools,
it's the blue-detuned laser.
So you should wonder about it.
There is really something
new to be learned.
So I want to motivate you to
follow me today and next week
through an alternative
description
of what light does to atoms
using the dressed atom picture,
and in the dressed
atom picture, we
will very naturally
understand why
now blue-detuned light
provides cooling.
But right now, for you,
this should be a mystery,
but it should be something
where you say, hey,
still something
qualitative is missing
in our understanding
of light forces.
OK, I will not be
able to explain
it [? physically ?] to you.
I first have to introduce
the dressed atom picture,
and I will do that it
in 10 minutes or so.
But what I want to do
here is if I'm telling you
something goes terribly
wrong and we completely
miss even the sign of the
force, blue-detuned light is now
cooling, not red-detuned
light, I at least
want to tell you
what went wrong.
Because haven't we done
an almost exact discussion
of light forces?
We used the gradient of d dot e.
We used for d the steady state
solution of the optical Bloch
equations.
Haven't we done
everything right?
Well, we did approximations.
And what happens is,
and this is the reason
for those qualitatively
different things, that we
should, in order to get
those effects, not use,
for the dipole moment, for the
off-diagonal matrix elements
of the density matrix,
the steady state solution
for optical Bloch vector.
We have to acknowledge that
it always takes a finite time
to reach steady state.
For instance, if he takes, let's
say, a spontaneous emission
time, if the atom goes
through a standing wave,
it goes from high
intensity to low intensity,
it takes about one
spontaneous emission time.
When you are highly
excited, but now you
go through a node of
the standing wave,
the steady state
solution is [INAUDIBLE].
At the node of the standing
wave, there is no light.
The steady state
solution with no light
is you better go back
to the ground state,
but that takes
something on the order
of the spontaneous
emission time.
So therefore, when I
am excited because I'm
in the middle of the
[? pied ?] laser beam
and I go fast into
the dark region,
I'm still excited because
I didn't have time
to get rid of my excitation.
In other words, the
internal degree of freedom,
the population of
grounded excited state,
will lag behind the
steady state solution
by a lag time which is a
spontaneous emission time.
And that would mean if I
multiply with the velocity,
it's pretty much that there
is a spacial displacement.
I'm always a certain distance
away from the steady state
solution.
And actually, this point,
to introduce the lag time,
we with do it in a
wonderful, physical way when
we have the dressed
atom picture,
but it can be done with
optical Bloch equation.
It's just a real pain because
the optical Bloch equation
is sort of like a
matrix the equation.
It's completely
obscure, how it is done,
but in order that you
convince yourself,
I posted the original paper
from Gordon and Ashkin
where this was done.
You read the math.
You understand the
result, but you
don't understand the derivation,
the physical picture behind it.
The dressed atom picture will
give us a lucid explanation
for exactly what a
lag time does and why
this results in colling.
But anyway, this is the
physics we have done wrong.
At low power, it's OK.
At high power, we really
have to take care of effect.
And if we would take care
of effect-- And as I said,
we don't need the
dressed atom picture,
we can fully do it within the
framework of the optical Bloch
equation, but it's messy.
--we would actually get out, and
you see that in the references,
the result that the friction
coefficient in a standing wave
at weak power is exactly two
times the friction coefficient
for a travelling wave, and
that justifies that we describe
molasses by the spontaneous
light force of two travelling
waves, completely ignoring
the standing wave.
But the same treatment of
the optical Bloch equation
will then, eventually,
give us the result
that alpha changes
sign at high intensity.
But as I said, I
want to describe
that after we have introduced
the dressed atom picture.
Questions?
OK, we have done molasses
in one dimension.
We have done beam slowing.
We just did a short
discussion about molasses
in arbitrary dimensions.
The one technique
which is missing now
is the magneto-optic trap.
Let me just spend five
minutes to discuss
the background behind
the magneto-optic trap
because for many of you,
I think you were just
born when the magneto-optic
trap was invented.
Well, I joined
the field in 1990,
and that was three years
after the magneto-optic trap
has been invented.
And many people say if there is
one most singular development
in laser cooling and
such, it's molasses
and the magneto-optical trap.
So let me tell you why,
the magneto-optical trap,
you shouldn't take
it for granted.
It was actually in
1983 that Ashkin--
Was it Gordon or Ashkin?
I think Ashkin, Art Ashkin.
--that he presented an
Optical Earnshaw theorem,
and it is nicely described
in Bill Phillips' Varenna
notes which I have
posted on the website.
And it's pretty much a proof
that you cannot build a trap
using the spontaneous
light force.
So in other words,
this is a proof
which people took
as a correct proof
that something like
the magneto-optic trap
could not exist.
So what this is proof like?
Well, and that
sort of teaches you
what was the mental concept
or the mental barrier people
had to break through
before they invented
the magneto-optic trap.
The proof is the following.
If you think that you
have beams-- I mean,
a model for the spontaneous
light force is you have photons
and the photons are
sand blasting the atom.
Each photon is like
a grain of sand,
and the atom is in scattering
descent in all directions.
You can really make this
completely classical picture
of the spontaneous light force.
Almost.
If you do with that you would
say the spontaneous light force
is proportional to
the stream of photons
which is described by
the Poynting vector.
But now, you have
in electromagnetism
a continuity equation which says
the divergence of the Poynting
vector plus the change of energy
density in a certain volume
has to be 0.
So if you are in
steady state-- If you
have an arrangement
of laser beams
and the energy density of
the electromagnetic field
is at steady state,
that tells you
that the divergence of the
Poynting vector has to be 0.
Well, if the divergence
of the Poynting vector
is 0, using this
equation that says
the divergence of the
spontaneous light force
has to be 0.
But if the divergence
of the force
has to be 0, that means you
can not have a force which
is inward from all directions
because such a force,
a trap needs a force
which is inward.
A trap requires a
negative divergence.
Do you see the wrong
assumption in this proof,
or did I convince you that
the magneto-optic trap is not
possible because this
proof would say you can not
make a trap out of the
spontaneous light force?
AUDIENCE: Well, you through out
the change in energy density,
so that's--
PROFESSOR: But that's
OK because if you switch
on a laser beam, light
travels at the speed of light,
and in 10 to the minus 10
seconds, in picoseconds,
you reach steady state.
And you know when
you operate the MOT,
you're not switching on and
off your lasers at picoseconds.
It's not that.
Yes, [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: --the
spacial variation of c.
PROFESSOR: Yes, exactly.
The force is not just
proportional to the Poynting
vector.
This would be true if
I had grains of sand,
but photons have to fill
a resonance condition.
You can maybe
assume I'm an atom,
but I have an spatially varying
magnetic field around me.
At the one magnetic
field, I feel the force
of the laser beam
because I am resonant.
At another magnetic
field, the laser beam
just goes through me because
I'm not in resonance.
So therefore, the
proportionality
between the Poynting
vector of the laser
beam and the light force
ignores that the light force
is resonant, that the
light force depends
on polarization and such.
So the solution
is the divergence
of-- If the c parameter
is spatially dependent,
then we can have a divergence,
and then, we can do trapping.
And it was actually Dave
Pritchard in '85 or in '86
who wrote a really
influential paper.
He said the Optical Earnshaw
theorem can be circumvented.
We can have a spatially
dependent factor,
and what can be spatially
dependent is saturation.
If you focus a laser beam,
you have a spatially varying
saturation parameter.
There can be some
optical pumping.
There can be light--
So he discussed
several possibilities
how the Optical Earnshaw
theorem was circumvented.
At this point in 1986,
he didn't realize
that it can be done with
a magnetic field gradient.
When he talked about possible
ways of circumventing
the Optical Earnshaw theorem,
Jean Dalibard, who many of who
know, who's a famous
researcher in our field,
had the idea that applying
a magnetic field gradient
could work.
But nobody thought,
at this time,
that it would work
in three dimensions,
so the fact that it
works in three dimensions
is almost a miracle.
So when the idea was born,
all those schemes, and also
the original idea of applying
a magnetic field gradient,
were conceived as
one dimension scheme.
Most of the schemes can
not be easily generalized
to three dimension,
but the MOT scheme
works as well in three dimension
as it works in one dimension.
Anyway, so this is
sort of the background.
Since I was a postdoc
when there were only two
or three groups who were
operating a magneto-optic trap,
I put together,
with my own hands,
the first magneto-optic trap
which was ever used at MIT.
I mean, it's ancient
history, so I
wanted to share a little
bit this history to you.
But let me now simply
describe to you
how the magneto-optic
trap works.
Let me describe it
for an atom which
we are not using in the lab.
We all usually use atoms which
have hyperfine structure.
But let me just for
pedagogical simplicity
assume that we have an atom
which has an s to p transition,
and in the p transition,
we have the three different
magnetic [? quantum ?] numbers.
So it's a simplified model.
And what we're
doing right now is
we are applying molasses, two
beams which act as molasses,
but there is one difference now.
They have different
polarizations, sigma plus
and sigma minus,
and in addition, we
apply a linear magnetic
field gradient.
So what happens now
is the following.
The linear magnetic
field gradient
does Zeeman shifts in
the opposite direction
to the n plus 1 and
n minus 1 level.
Now, the transition to m minus
1 is done by sigma plus light.
The transition to m plus 1
is done by sigma minus light.
So what happens now
is if you have an atom
and it moves away
from the origin,
it will eventually come
closer and closer in resonance
with the sigma plus light,
but the sigma plus light
comes from the left side so
the atom will be pushed back.
If the atom moves out hear, it
moves further and further away,
in resonance, from
the sigma plus light,
but it moves now, in resonance,
over the sigma minus light,
and the sigma minus light
is pushing the atoms back.
So this geometry has an inward
force from both directions
and therefore, works as a trap.
So let me now describe
it mathematically
which is very, very simple.
What we have to do is we
just have, like in molasses,
two laser beams two
times the expression
for the spontaneous light force.
And you'll remember we
got the molasses equation
by taking the two laser beams
and putting in the Doppler
shift which is a
velocity dependent shift.
Well, all we have to do is,
for those two laser beams,
we have to put now a spatially
dependent Zeeman shift which
varies linearly with position.
So therefore, all we have to
do is we sum up the total force
as the spontaneous
force for the right
and for the left laser
beam, and in addition
to the molasses effect, we put
now in the spatial dependence.
So we don't have to
do the math again.
We did already a
Taylor expansion in v,
but let's now just
do a Taylor expansion
in the blue expression.
And then, we find that there
is a linearly restoring force
both in velocity space and
in configuration space which
actually tells you
something interesting.
The more friction you have, the
larger is the restoring force.
So the trapping and the
cooling are really connected,
at least in the simple model
of the spontaneous light force.
OK, so if we have
this kind of force,
a linear force in velocity,
a linear force in position,
this is the equation of
motion of a damped harmonic
oscillator.
You have a spatial
force constant, k,
this linear force which
is linear in displacement.
So this is a damped
harmonic oscillator.
Usually, you don't
see atoms sloshing
in your magneto-optic trap
like in an harmonic oscillator
because if you look through
the [? typical ?] numbers
and by just doing
the Taylor expansion
of the spontaneous light
force, you can immediately
get an alluded expressions
for those numbers.
In almost all cases,
the harmonic oscillator
is overdamped.
So that's how the
magneto-optic trap works.
However, the magneto-optic
trap is not so simple.
I would actually
say nobody fully
understands the
magneto-optic trap
because we have
multi-level structure.
We don't have just
one count level.
A sodium and a
rubidium atom has--
f equals one and f equals two--
has eight different hyperfine
levels.
So there is not one level
and we can excite the atoms.
There are eight
different levels.
And those laser beams to optical
pumping among those eight
levels, and you have to
solve a rate equation
for eight different levels.
And the amazing thing
is it still works.
It still works
pretty much, at least
qualitatively, as well as
I just described to you.
So it's a combination of optical
pumping and Zeeman shifts.
It even works better
than advertised
because as I will tell
you in the next few weeks,
you can reach
temperatures-- Because
of the multi-level
structure, you
reach temperatures which are
much colder than the Doppler
limit.
It's called polarization
gradient cooling.
It's just if you
have laser beams
and you have atoms with
hyperfine structure,
they are colder than
the Doppler limit.
First, nobody understood
it, and then, Bill Phillips
figured it out.
And that he figured
out why atoms
get colder that
was the main point
emphasized by the
Nobel Committee
when he got the Nobel
Prize for laser cooling.
Of course, he had already
invented Zeeman slowing before,
so he had a few other
things under his belt.
But anyway, the fact
that the MOT works
even better than advertised
is another miracle,
and this is related to
the hyperfine structure.
And finally, the fact that
you can simply extended it
to three dimension, is-- I said
the first, the second --maybe
the third miracle.
It also works.
Because when you
look at the field
of two coils, a so-called
Anti-Helmholtz field,
there are some directions
where the magnetic field is not
radially outward.
This is a much more
complicated magnetic field.
It goes outward
here, outward here,
but in between the quadrupolar
field, it sort of curves.
There are some directions
where the magnetic field is not
radial, and you would say, hey,
the one dimensional scheme is
[INAUDIBLE] [? set. ?]
Actually, before the
magneto-optic trap
was demonstrated, Dave
Pritchard's student,
Eric [? Rob ?] did
calculations what
happens in these
diagonal directions which
have no resemblance to
the one dimension scheme.
The solution is in
those directions,
the trapping form is
a little bit weaker,
but the big picture
is it doesn't matter.
So there was an idea
conceived in one dimension
for a simple atom structure,
and this idea worked even better
for real atoms and
in three dimensions.
OK, in your homework
assignment, you
will put in some
numbers which show
what happens if you take
a vapor, an alkali vapor
at a very low density of 10
to the 8 per cubic centimeter,
pressure of, typically, 10
to the minus 8 [? Tor, ?]
and you arrange six
laser beams around it.
Well, those laser beams have
a restoring force in velocity.
That means they cool and
increase the phase space
density over your sample
by 8 orders of magnitude.
Those laser beams have
also a restoring force
in the spatial dimension.
Therefore, you get
a cloud which has
3 orders of magnitude
higher density.
So the temperature goes down
by 8 orders of magnitude
which means the phase
space density is enhanced
by 12 orders of magnitude.
So if you're talking
about the goal of reaching
Bose-Einstein condensation
which requires a phase space
density of 1, just
having a dilute vapor
and these six laser beams with
a little bit of magnetic field,
increases your
phase space density
by 15 orders of magnitude.
So this is why molasses and
the MOT were a real milestone.
Now, with 15 orders
of magnitude,
you are just 4 or 5
orders of magnitude
from Bose-Einstein
condensation, and we
will discuss, in
a week and a half,
what techniques were
needed to bridge
the gap between those
temperatures and densities
and quantum
degeneracy of gasses.
So that's the story of
the magneto-optic trap.
I'm also telling
you that because I'm
proud that a lot of the
pioneering work in this regard
happened at MIT.
It was Dave Pritchard who
realized at the Optical
Earnshaw theorem
can be circumvented,
and it was him, in a
collaboration with Steve Chu,
that they together realized
the first magneto-optic trap,
and this was in 1987.
Questions?
OK, I think simple applications
of the spontaneous light force.
So we have time to talk
about the dressed atom.
Now, I was waiting
until this point
to introduce the dressed
atom picture for you
because the dressed atom picture
is the natural picture you want
to think about, for instance,
for the Mollow triplet,
and we had already some
discussion about it.
But it is also the
natural picture
you want to think about
it when you describe
the stimulated light force.
And I mentioned already, it is
the dressed atom picture which
will help me to give you the
physical picture behind if you
have strong laser beams,
why blue-detuned light cools
and not red-detuned light.
So you should be motivated now
to learn about the dressed atom
picture.
But first, I have
to say it's not
anything new, what
I'm teaching you.
It has exactly the
same physics in it
as the optical Bloch equations.
It's just that the optical
Bloch equations are
often more complicated,
and they don't
provide the clear insight.
And the reason is the following.
Often when you describe
a physical phenomenon,
you can choose one basis set, or
you can use another basis set.
But if you're in
the wrong basis,
you get the correct results,
but in the wrong basis,
you just can't describe
the physics easily.
So in other words, with
the dressed atom picture,
I want to introduce dressed
atom states for you which
are no longer the ground
state and the excited state.
I want to treat the
atoms dressed up
by the laser beam,
which is one mode
of the electromagnetic field.
So the atoms, together
with this one laser beam,
will be partially excited,
partially in the ground state.
And this partially
excited atoms, this
is the dressed atom basis.
But if you think in
terms of those states,
you have a much easier
way to formulate
certain physical processes,
exactly processes
where you have high laser power.
At low laser power,
the dress states
are identical to
the naked states
to the ground and
excited states.
But at high laser power,
at infinite laser power,
the two dressed states are the
symmetric and anti-symmetric
equal superposition of
grounded and excited state.
So that's what we
want to describe now.
So the difference to the
Optical Bloch Equation
is that we are
now really looking
for the combined
state of the atom
in the electromagnetic field.
So what we want to do is--
this is sort of our picture
that we have.
This is our Hamiltonian.
We have the atom
interacting with the vacuum
through spontaneous
emission with a reservoir
of empty modes.
But now, it also interacts
with the laser beam.
And you remember when we
did the master equation,
we looked sort of at this.
We derived a master
equation for this.
And then we added
in the unitary time
evolution due to laser beam.
But what we want to
do now is we want
to first take care of the
atom and the laser beam
almost exactly in an
exact diagonalization.
And once we have
re-diagonalized that,
we have now eigenstates which
we call the dressed states.
Then we allow not the
ground and excited state.
We then allow the dressed
states to emit into the vacuum.
And this is the formulation
we want to obtain now.
Let me make one
comment before I go
through a few simple equation,
and that's the following.
If I want to treat this
system almost exactly,
I have two choices.
I use a strong laser beam.
So I could, as we have
discussed several times,
simply use the time dependent
external electric field.
The laser beam is E0
times cosine omega t.
And I just introduced
that in the Hamiltonian.
And you can get
everything I describe now
for you out of this Hamiltonian.
However, there is
an alternative way.
And this one is I simply
assume that the laser beam is
described by the
fully quantized field.
And I use the fog state.
I just assume N, the number
of photons, is very big.
And this is, at least
for that purpose,
a valid description
of the laser beam.
So what happens is you really
want to look through that.
I've really learned
a lot by comparing
the purely classical
treatment of the laser beam
and the fully quantized
description of the laser beam.
The results are the same.
They are Absolutely identical.
And what you will see is, by
a bunch of approximations,
we reduce the total
Hamiltonian to-- I've
seen it many times--
a two by two matrix.
And whether you start
with the classical field
or whether you start with
the fully quantized field,
if you make the
right approximation,
you get the same
two by two matrix.
But there's a difference.
This Hamiltonian is
time independent.
a dagger a, time
independent Hamiltonian.
If you take a classical field,
which is cosine omega lt,
you don't have a time
independent Hamiltonian.
You have a driven system,
and your wave function
has an external time dependence.
The laser beam is driving
the wave function.
So in other words,
you have two choices
when you want to describe
how an atom interacts
with a strong laser beam.
You can use the fully quantized
field, which is conceptionally
a little bit more
complicated, because we've
quantized the
electromagnetic field.
But then everything
is time independent,
and everything I do
here is really easy.
I can go over it
now in five minutes,
and you understand everything.
Well, in your
homework, I've already
asked you at an early homework
to look at simply the two level
system driven by
classical field.
And in your next homework,
number 10, your last homework,
I'm asking you now to
interpret the solution
with the classical field.
And it's actually a
little bit a challenge
to take the time
dependent wave function
and read the physics out of this
time dependent wave function,
which corresponds to the physics
we derive in the dressed atom
picture.
But you have two ways.
One is the classical field.
Then the wave function, the
Hamiltonian, is time dependent.
And the wave function
is time dependent.
Or here, I start with
the quantum field
and everything is
time independent.
But the solutions are identical.
Well, one is a time
dependent wave function.
One is time independent.
But if you interpret
the solution
in terms of what happens
to the physical system,
you will find exactly the same.
So in other words, I decided
I do the easy part here,
which is a fully quantized part.
And this is probably what
will get stuck in your head.
But since I think it's an
important pedagogical exercise,
you have to go
through the homework
and do the time dependent part.
OK, so we want to
know exactly-- well
not-- we want to do the
correct approximations.
And after some
approximations, exactly
solve what the atom does
with one laser beam.
So the laser beam is described
by the standard Hamiltonian
for single mode light.
The atom is described by, well,
excitation energy omega 0.
And b is the excited state.
So if you don't have any
light atom interaction,
the eigenstates are just product
states, an atom in the excited
or the ground state.
And N is the photon number.
[? Collin? ?]
AUDIENCE: You said that
it's usually easier
to understand physics
in a dressed atom
picture versus optical
block equations.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can you think
of-- is that a general rule?
Or is this just like it's only
applicable in certain areas?
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: You're really
asking an expert question.
And I talked to Jean Dalibard
and Claude Cohen-Tannoudji,
who invented the dressed
atom picture, when
I wanted to understand
what happens when
we have a blue detuned lattice.
And I used the dressed atom
picture and I got confused.
So what happened
is the following.
If you pick your right bases,
the description is simple.
But simple means
if all the physics
is your atom is in
one dressed state
or the other dressed state,
and it does transitions
between the dressed
states and that is easy,
and this happens in the
limit of large detuning.
But if you're in
the regime where
coherences between the
dressed states matter.
In other words, the density
matrix in the dressed state
basis has now off
diagonal matrix element.
The physics becomes
complicated again.
So in other words, what
I'm telling you is you
are the best description
happens when we have a two level
system, we always need
a two by two matrix.
But if you pick the description
where the solution is diagonal,
if you have to deal with
coherence, using coherence
is coupled to population,
it's complicated.
And there's some cases-- one is
the blue detuned lattice, which
I encounter where you have to
consider the coherences to get
the correct answer.
And usually, also when
the laser beams are weak
and on resonance, the
dressed atom picture
is not providing any advantages.
So you want to use the bare
picture for weak excitations.
And yes, in the resonance
case, the dressed atom picture,
if you're very
close to resonance,
the dressed atom picture
gets more complicated.
But to give you the answer in
something we have discussed,
you know already that when
you drive an atom with a laser
beam, you get the
Mollow triplet.
And the Mollow
triplet shows you--
I hope we can finish that
today-- shows you the energy
splitting between the
dressed energy levels,
between the dressed
energy levels.
But if the Mollow
triplet is not resolved
because the generalized
Rabi frequency is small,
then you're not resolving
your dressed atom levels.
And then the dressed
atom level is not
providing a big advantage.
For certain problems,
the dressed atom picture
will not help you.
But I can reassure
you, and this is
what I learned from
Jean Dalibard and Claude
Cohen-Tannoudji,
if you really look
at the full matrix with the
off diagonal matrix append
and everything, you will always
find exactly the same solution.
Anyway, we were
just writing down
product states of the atoms
and the eigenfunctions
of the Hamiltonian
for the light, which
are fog states, number
states with N, L N plus 1.
But the important thing
is now the following.
In the limit of small
detuning, the ground state
with N plus 1 photon is almost
degenerate with the excited
state with N photons.
And we call these two
states a manifold.
The manifold E of N. And
N is the photon number
in the excited state.
So what happens is, if you
look at all those states,
they are grouped into manifolds.
And the energy separation
between two manifolds
is, of course, I go from N to N
plus 1, the energy of a photon.
So now I introduce the
atom laser coupling
in the usual dipole
approximation.
And what happens is, this
dipole approximation,
this dipole light atom coupling
will couple, of course,
ground and excited state.
And it will, of course,
have a big effect
when the energy
splitting is small.
Well, you will see
that in the next line.
But we have the co and
counter rotating terms.
This dipole Hamiltonian will
also couple the ground state
to the excited state
in the other manifold.
This is the off resonant
term, which will be neglect.
So here are the
equations for that.
Our electric field is, of
course, a plus a dagger.
The dipole operator is that.
And if you take what is in
front of the electric field
and define this as the
coupling constant, g,
we have what I just told
you, that within a manifold,
the ground state
with N plus 1 photons
is coupled to the excited
state with N photons.
g is simply the
coupling constant,
which all parameters have
been included in that.
But then, because of the matrix
element of a or a dagger,
we have the square
root of N plus 1.
OK, so what we are now doing is
we are going with this coupling
within a manifold, which
is strong because the two
levels are energetically close.
And we will neglect the
non-resonant couplings
to the other manifolds.
And that's just another
way of doing, again,
the rotating wave approximation.
Now, when we describe an atom
in the laser field and the atom
scatters light, or
we have a laser beam,
and I have to tell you,
when we have a laser beam,
we don't provide exactly
N atom, N photons.
The laser beam is
in a coherent state.
And there are
Poissonian fluctuations.
But now, we do the next
approximation, namely we
say when N is
large, then delta N
can be neglected
with regard to N.
Then at least for the
range of important photon
numbers for the problem, this
coupling becomes independent
of N. And we simply take the
average number of photons
in our laser beam and define
now an electric field, which
is independent of N.
And the product with
the dipole operator
of the atom, that's what
we call the Rabi frequency.
So at that point, we introduce
a classical electric field
through this definition, and
therefore, the dressed atom
picture.
Also, we start with the fully
quantized Hamiltonian is now
identical to the classical
field with this electric field
amplitude.
But what we have gained is
we could discuss everything
in a time independent picture.
And now, I promised you,
we'll go back to a two
by two matrix, which you
have seen many times.
It's a two level system.
We have the detuning.
We are in the rotating frame.
So that means the ground and
excited state with N and N
minus 1 photons have
the same energy.
But if we have a detuning,
there is a difference
whether we excite the
atom or whether we
put a photon in the laser field.
But you have seen
that many, many times.
And the coupling
is now described
by the Rabi frequency.
So that's kind of
our typical two level
system where the two levels
[INAUDIBLE] the rotating frame,
everything is time independent.
The two levels are split,
and they are coupled.
And well, how many times have
you seen the solution of two
by two matrix?
The solution is that
the coupling is now
increasing the splitting.
The splitting between
the two levels
is, again, the generalized
Rabi frequency,
which you have seen
many, many times.
But now we want to really
get the wave function.
We want to get something out
of the dressed atom picture.
And that's the following.
We started out with the
bare states-- ground
state with N plus 1, excited
state with N photons.
And the two by two matrix
after the diagonalization
is now a linear
combination of those.
And it's convenient to use
sine theta, cosine theta,
because then the states are
automatically normalized.
If I introduce the
solution is now
that the angle theta is
given by this equation,
that's just the solution
for the two by two matrix.
And the physical picture,
which we have obtained,
is the following.
If this here is the energy
of the excited state with N
photons, I've just sort of drawn
this as a reference parallel.
But now I want to draw it
as a function of the laser
frequency.
Well, the ground state
with N plus 1 photons
has exactly the same
energy on resonance.
But if the photon is more
energetic then this state,
because it has N plus 1
photons versus n photons
if the photon is more energetic
than a resonant photon,
this state has higher energy.
And here, it has lower energy.
In other words, we
have now a level
crossing between
the two bare states.
But a level crossing
with interaction
turns into an avoided crossing.
And the solution which
we have just derived
are the blue curves.
And if I go far
away from resonance,
this behavior here,
which is perturbative,
is nothing else than
the AC Stark shift.
So this is exactly what we
have discussed at this point.
Now, let's get some
mileage out of it.
And we will talk
about light forces.
That's really interesting.
And I hope it's another
highlight of this course
to describe light forces in
the dressed atom picture.
But what I want to
do here is already
in preparation for that.
I want to not yet
introduce forces, simply
figure out what happens in
the dressed atom picture
when the atoms scatter light.
And you know already
the solution.
The solution is
the Mollow triplet.
And we have discussed with
the Optical Bloch Equations
that at low laser power,
the Mollow triplet
has three curves.
It has three broadened curves.
And they have
different broadening.
And I didn't prove it to
you, but I mentioned to you,
at low laser power there is--
perturbative laser power,
we discussed at great length
that there's a delta function.
And at low laser power,
the delta function remains.
So this is sort of the
spectrum we get out of it.
And what I want
to show you now is
how this spectrum is described
in the dressed atom picture.
Atom photon interaction
has a wonderful discussion
of all the details.
I will share with
you a few highlights.
But we will go much further in
the description of the Mollow
triplet then we've gone before.
But I will not go into
all excruciating details.
So let's discuss first.
That's something we
hadn't done so far.
What are the intensities
in this Mollow triplet?
So the way how we obtain
it is the following.
We have the manifold, the
manifold with N minus 1
and the manifold with N photons.
And this is the detuning.
And if we allow for the
atom laser coupling,
the splitting here is a
generalized Rabi frequency.
And well, you immediately see
that in this picture, if you
allow spontaneous emission from
the upper manifold to the lower
manifold, you have four
different combinations.
One is the long photon
is the blue sideband.
This is the red sideband.
This is the blue sideband.
And those two are the carriers.
But now, we can
do the following.
I've just written down for
you the solution of the wave
function with sine
and cosine theta.
If we want to emit the blue
sideband, we go from the top
to the bottom.
But that means, since a
photon in the rotating wave
approximation can only be
emitted when we go from b to a,
we find that the
matrix element for that
involves cosine theta
times sine theta.
However, if you want
to emit the carrier,
you go from here to there.
Well, we always have to find
the excited state to begin with.
And we go-- I must
have made a mistake.
Sorry.
When I went to emit
the blue side, when
I go from all the way
up to all the way down,
and I always have to find
an excited state which
connects to the ground state.
And this gives me a term,
which is cosine square.
The red detuned sideband
gives me sine squared.
And if I want to get
the carrier, this one,
I go from here to here.
I get cosine theta sine theta.
So in other words,
we can immediately
read off the matrix elements.
And since the intensity,
Fermi's Golden Rule,
is the matrix
element squared, we
find immediately that the upper
lower sideband and the carrier
involve terms cosine to the
4 theta, sine to the 4 theta,
cosine square sine square.
So we got the matrix element.
And the only thing
we have to know now
is that the width or the rate
is given by the matrix element.
The rate is given by the
matrix element square.
But now, what is the
intensity of the line?
Well, the upper
sideband is emitted
by the upper dressed
state, because you
have to go from the
upper dressed state
to the lower dressed state to
get the blue detuned photon.
So therefore, the
intensity for this sideband
is this rate times
the population
in the upper dressed state.
So what is missing
at this point,
and we need that urgently
for next week, what
is the population in the
upper and the lower sideband?
Well, we know the
transition rates
between the upper and
the lower sidebands--
well, between the upper
and lower dressed state.
We know we've just
found here the rate.
What is the rate?
What is the matrix element
squared when you go from one
is the upper, two is the
lower state of the manifold.
So we have just
gotten those rates.
And rate equation says,
the change of population
in the upper dressed
state is given
by the departure
from the upper state
and what arrives
from the lower state.
So since we are interested
in the steady state solution,
we can just set the
left side to zero.
And then, the rate
equations simply
give us the population
in terms of the rates.
So in other words, if you
ask, what is the steady state
solution in the upper
or lower dressed state,
it's given by a ratio of
those rate coefficients.
But we just got those
rate coefficients.
And this gives us another bunch
of sine and cosine functions.
So in other words,
we know now what
is the population of
the dressed states.
I mean, everything is expressed
by one non-trivial parameter
theta.
And all we get is sine square,
cosine square, sine to the 4th,
we just get those
trigonometric functions.
Yes.
I think we can finish that.
Good.
So this is the steady
state solution.
But now, we can go back
to the rate equation
and say the time derivative
of the rate equation
has to relax to
the steady state.
This is nothing else than
rewriting the equation above.
But by rewriting the
equation above in that way,
we find now the
prefactor in front of-- I
mean, here, what you have is
the time derivative is given
by the difference
from steady state.
And this is the
relaxation coefficient.
And the relaxation coefficient
is-- that's the solution.
You just have to do the
substitutions yourself.
The relaxation coefficient,
how populations
relax to steady
state, is now given
by the sum of the two rates.
One is going from the
upper to the lower
and from the lower
to the upper state.
And each of those rates
has been expressed
by sine square and
cosine squares.
I'm not doing it here,
because it's a little bit more
complicated.
But you can also rewrite for
the dressed atom picture what
happens-- you can rewrite those
equations in a way what happens
not to the population, but
what happens to the coherences,
to the off diagram
matrix element formulated
in the dressed state basis.
And what you find is, you find
a correlation time, a relaxation
time, for the coherences.
Remember, for the naked
state, population's
relaxed with gamma.
Coherence is relaxed
with gamma over 2.
This is for the Optical
Bloch Equations.
But now we have reformulated
the physics in the dressed atom
picture.
And what the solution
is the following.
This is sort of a
weak laser power.
But in the most general
case, what you will find
is that the width
of the central peak
reflects the relaxation
time for the population.
And the width for the sidebands
is the relaxation time
for the coherences in
the dressed atom picture.
So we had before with the
Optical Bloch Equations,
I showed you different cases.
We had a three quarter gamma.
I need two more minutes and
I'm finished with my unit.
So we had weird factors
of three quarters.
And I showed you how they
come from the eigenvalues
of the matrix of the
Optical Bloch Equation.
But now we understand
them physically,
namely the central
feature has a peak,
which is the relaxation
time for the populations
in the dressed atom picture.
And the sidebands
have a width, which
is the relaxation time
for the coherences.
They no longer differ
by a factor of two,
as in the naked bases in which
we formulated the Optical Bloch
Equations.
By the way, I know
a lot of you may
be curious about
the coherent peak.
You can read about it in API.
It's 10 pages about
correlation function.
But in the end, the rate
of the delta function
can be, again, described by
values we have just calculated.
We have just calculated
steady state populations
and transition rates.
So this rate is nothing else
than another combination
of sine square and cosine
squares of this angle theta.
So everything is wonderfully
and simply described
the full physics of
that by just this angle
theta in the dressed
atom picture.
OK So with that, we are done.
And I think I'll discuss the
last page with you on Monday.